[Music]
hey what's up everyone welcome back to
the lobby game spots weekly video game
hangout i'm your host mike mccarty i'm
here with a bunch of great people as
always peter brown a regular on the show
yes what do you do here
well when you figure that out let me
know people have been commenting on your
coffee already in the chat last week you
had armored coffee the week before it
was teetering on the edge peter what's
it gonna do this week actually
did you like that what's it gonna do
this week it's nothing well just a
normal coffee i don't know what to tell
you guys i guess even that is kind of a
change up from last time callie plaguei
hi it's me what's up uh nothing much i
saw more anime yesterday you know that's
just what i do
is that like a
news don't you always watch anime
oh i saw your name which was fantastic
your name yeah it's a film
that's really good
that's what i've been up to but you're
getting gearing up for some star wars
right i am i'm going to star wars
celebration so i leave really late i
leave on friday everybody else is
already on their way to orlando to
orlando sunshine florida
it is the sunshine state actually
that joke doesn't work this time uh what
no aren't we the sunshine do you always
say golden state
okay
moving on from that one
we were both joking uh we'll get back to
more star wars later in the show we're
going to be talking about battlefront
2's league trailer uh michael hyam not
your first time in the lobby but first
time on the new set it's the first time
this year though yeah this is our
resident cool guy
if you can't tell already yeah i'm tired
but uh no michael what do you do here
for people i do tech coverage with jimmy
thang so
video cards pc components
we were talking about we're going to
talk about scorpio but i did a
pretty dope video about things you
should watch out for scorpio we did like
a tech analysis so six things you should
know i'm smarter than i actually see him
so
just be trust just
evaporating anybody's concerns right
away but yeah we will talk about scorpio
as well uh we got a full show today uh
but i do want to get through a couple of
uh news items and a giveaway as we've
been doing the last few weeks on the
gamespot uh shiva who runs our twitter
account we'll be tweeting in a few
minutes about uh do you have that
keyboard
the corsair strafe keyboard uh is
michael you know more about this
keyboard than i do you tell people about
it uh corsair strafe is a mechanical
keyboard with i believe it has red
mechanical switches which is linear no
tactile feel i actually like this
keyboard quite a bit you got them you
get some pretty dope
textured keycaps right there so you
never lose track your wasd sweet uh and
it's lit
red
quite literally
so uh yeah we'll be giving that away i
guess
you're just waiting for that weren't you
so shiva who manages our twitter account
we'll be tweeting from the gamespot
account if you don't follow us please do
so and then retweet said tweet about the
giveaway and then later on the week
we'll pick a random winner uh in north
america uh possibly only u.s i think yes
yes so uh
yeah get on that and uh later in the
week you'll find out who won uh and then
i do have a couple of news items before
we get into our main segments uncharted
the lost legacy price and release date
revealed for the spin-off featuring
nadine ross and chloe frazier from
uncharted 2 and uncharted 4 and 2
respectively uh it'll be 40 it'll be out
on august 22nd
for ps4 um it's naughty dog's like uh
first spin-off for the series and this
is the from what you know what we
understand the last
uh entry in the uncharted universe uh
before you know that we see the last of
us two whenever that actually releases
uh so yeah you'll be able to play that
at the end of the summer kind of right
around when a shot of war comes out if
you're looking for a different
experience than that so yeah we're
looking forward to that uh breath of the
wild has another patch out now and in
true nintendo patch update fashion they
didn't really go into details uh doesn't
it say it makes for a more pleasant
gameplay experience yes uh the patch
from breath of wild according to
nintendo this is what they said it
allows for a more pleasant gaming
experience uh so that last one was the
one that kind of uh helped the frame
rate out on switch and wii u i'm not
mistaken
sure yeah and uh it actually it looked
much better when you're in those heavily
forced areas this one
uh
again
that's what the patch notes say adjust
adjustments have been made to make for
more pleasant gaming experience
so if you want that
go for it all right if you're if you're
not enjoying zelda enough already uh and
last on the news unless uh diablo 3s
necromancer closed beta is live now uh
so if you previously registered for that
should show up on your blizzard account
management page um
the necromancer from diablo 2 of diablo
2 fame tay's going to kill me if that's
wrong uh eric i think diablo 2 yeah yeah
uh he specializes in you know bringing
back dead enemies kind of uh
those kind of attacks and this will be
this is not just pc right now but um
when this actual major patch releases
it'll have new areas more
more rifts refined rifts and more areas
in the adventure mode for the game which
i'm looking forward to because i always
love an excuse to get back to diablo 3
and that is everything on our news item
list today so now
as michael previously alluded to we are
going to get into
project scorpio talk because uh digital
foundry releases specs was it last week
yeah uh yeah it was last week there's
there's that stream right and you guys
came in early to cover it or at least it
released early so and then pete
obviously like follows this the kind of
hardware
stuff pretty frequently yeah um cali
you a hardware person
i built my own pc that's like that's
that's more than what more than what i
know
yeah all right cool uh so let me just
start with the basics michael hit me
with the specs uh what is this like uh
so well i'm not gonna run down like all
the specs because that can get do every
single one of them
i'm just kidding well as an eight core
cpu 2.3 gigahertz based on jaguar
architecture it's improved this time
they actually do have six teraflops for
in layman's terms teraflops is just a
measurement of how powerful something is
graphically
and it seems that they're actually
hitting that they have 12 gigs of ram on
that eight dedicated games four for the
dashboard so and i'm anticipating that
that's actually going to be a pretty big
deal because you know getting in and out
of the xbox dashboard can kind of be a
pain so if you dedicate ram to that
specifically
i imagine it would be smoother i sure
hope so because the interfaces
can be rough sometimes
so that's uh and it's gonna have a vapor
chamber cooling and be vaping in your
this thing can face
it's gonna damn it's gonna be everything
no but vapor changing chamber cooling is
actually a pretty
i've heard it's an efficient way of
keeping your um
your stuff pretty cool man yeah without
having too many fans going as well right
that's another passive solution quieter
yeah it shouldn't be like a jet engine
because right yeah
so those are kind of the basic specs but
um yeah you can check all that
information out on several websites but
the the main thing though for me was
that forza tech demo that they showed
off so they were showing off native 4k
for a console which i think is pretty
impressive it was running 60 frames per
second but
you'll see a lot of in headlines oh 4k
60 fps so scorpio is going to be like so
dope but you know it's just the forza
tech demo you know other games are going
to perform differently
so
you know saying that everything's gonna
be 60 fps is that's probably more i'm
willing to bet it's not going to be true
and this is also like the forza games
are hard surface 3d models that are not
as like diverse in terms of textures and
all the different layers of textures
that go into handling lighting as
something like an organic model would be
like a scene full of hundreds of humans
right right one car is very different
than a lot of that yeah they did um a in
the demo they maxed out how many cars
they could put on there to kind of
stress test it a little bit
but you know
cars don't animate also and they don't
explode and you know there's not display
transformers
that they don't not enforce it at all
but uh so in terms of like particle
effects and post-processing you know
it's an easy easy comparison to make but
back in the day when like ps4 pro was on
the horizon and then the scorpio is
still kind of this nebulous thing uh you
know microsoft kept saying it was going
to be more powerful that's easy
comparison but how does it compare to
the ps4 pro at least from these uh the
specs we've gotten
well it's about 40 it's supposed to be
about 40 43
more powerful
than the ps4 pro so
that was the expectation that it was
going to be more powerful than the ps4
pro so there's no surprise there
um
and you know doing the uh because ps4
pro doesn't do native 4k i don't believe
or there are maybe some cases it doesn't
have a work around
a couple games or other games that will
scale like it'll render at a slightly
lower resolution and then bump it up
yeah okay yeah so
if scorpio says they're gonna do native
okay they obviously have to be more
powerful than the ps4 pro
another thing is what compromises are
they going to have to make for future
games because as games go on they're
going to be more and more demanding so
if you want to keep up with 4k you're
going to have to scale back other things
like maybe draw distance or
you know post-processing or texture
quality
but it is more powerful than the ps4 pro
what does it mean for
um like cloud kind of when they were
running off the cloud when they were uh
showing off crackdown three at first
does that does the scorpio mean anything
for that like advancing that or could
you do that off a normal xbox one right
now that was a couple years ago i mean
the cloud stuff is uh totally
independent from the console in terms of
processing power right i mean maybe they
could try to do like a glimmer of what
they were showcasing with crackdown 2
which was literally fully destructible
environments in a multi-player scenario
yeah which is really crazy um
yeah the whole like cityscape was just
toppling over yeah like not i mean and
not in a way that was pre-animated like
it was all dynamic physics-driven stuff
which is nuts like little every little
bit and piece of a building
animating what about if you were to
compare this to like uh
i don't know to a nice pc
how would this compare oh jimmy's
actually gonna be working on that is
trying to build a pc that's similar to
the power of
the xbox
or project scorpio
right now i would say
the well in terms of teraflops the rx
480 the radeon rx 480 is about 5.8
teraflops so i guess there's there's no
one to one uh comparison that you can
make in terms of pc hardware but if you
can do a rough estimate the rx 480 i've
heard people saying that this can be as
powerful as a gtx 1070 and that's a
really good graphics card that you can
do 4k in some instances with like medium
to high settings so if it's if it's in
that range then you know
it's a pretty beefy console we don't
know the price yet but what would a
comparable pc like what would that cost
to build
um especially with that kind of graphics
card i think you could hit that for like
700 to 800 bucks just on the pc alone if
you don't factor in the well because an
operating system is going to cost 100 so
if you don't consider that like hardware
alone probably about seven hundred
bucks monitor and keyboard and all that
but yeah that's all the actual guts of
the yeah probably about 700 to 800 bucks
so it's a good segue i was actually
going to kind of ask go around the table
uh we do have a gamespot q a up on the
site about what like a bunch of our
editors and a couple producers think
about the price what the price will be
for the scorpio as it's not announced
yet um and then i just wanted to uh
ask you guys michael what do you think
it'll be
i said it's going to be 500 bucks
because if it's any cheaper that
hardware is actually like pretty damn
dope so i imagine it's going to be
expensive to make
so if you're going to if it's going to
be less than 500 bucks i would be
surprised that would be sweet because
then that's you know cheaper for
everyone else to buy
but i can't see it being any higher than
500 bucks because then like who that was
gonna buy it like i could get a you know
what come holiday season ps4 pros are
probably gonna be i'm not saying that
they are going to but it's likely that
they'll have like 50 price cut so around
350 compared to this
scorpio that would be 500 you know even
that thinking about that is a pretty
wide gap and thinking oh what console do
i want to buy so i can't see it any
higher than 500 bucks but this is pretty
powerful hardware in the console space
so that's what i'm saying you know what
i'm saying
kelly what about you yeah i imagine it
would be around 500. um i think it was
jimmy in that q a was talking about
the um point of entry for ps3 was so
high initially but the value of what you
were getting was actually really good
like it was the cheapest blu-ray player
you could get at the time
and so i think just learning from that
uh consumers not understanding that
right away
at face value i don't think it would go
higher than that just because even if
the value even if a comparable
comparable pc would be seven or eight
hundred dollars and this was if this was
500
people don't necessarily know that and
so i think it would be
hard to convince people to pick this
over
say a ps4 pro
if it went any higher than 500.
p what about you uh i don't know i think
the bigger question rather than the
hardware is what microsoft is really
trying to do with this product um so
right now the xbox one s is 250.
in my mind there's absolutely no way
they're gonna double that price for a
system that plays the exact same games
because then you're immediately saying
your customers like
well i don't know what that message
would be like you're trying to retain
like the highest the most enthusiastic
people but microsoft is not doing so hot
in terms of retaining their audience or
putting out great games so what are they
gonna play on this system right but if
you go up against the ps4 pro and
they're trying to win that audience back
hey if they can go 400 and match that
price they might convince people and tip
them over with the value that cali was
talking about
and
it's fair if you look in the past like
the history of gaming consoles companies
sell systems at a loss all the time yeah
so even if this costs 400 for them to
make they will lose that money to get
consumers back because they make far
more on software sales than they ever do
on hardware yeah i'm saying 400.
yeah i mean they haven't ps4 pro has how
many games that have like better
versions on ps4 pro i mean one of the
first ones was titanfall 2 and then i
know uncharted 4 the original last of us
they were updating naughty dog updated
those for the ps4 pro but like you said
it's not immediately apparent aside from
upgraded hardware what
the scorpio's wider
you've got to buy a new tv yeah i mean
what point is that 4k gaming if you
don't have a 4k tv right so well let me
tell you about that
it's just really quick so
i think that
for me this is kind of important for
people who are still on 1080p tvs is
that uh scorpio is going to
super sample your game so you'll get
like that
so super sampling is a type of
anti-aliasing so it'll take a 4k image
4k image and it'll shrink it down to
1080p so you'll get like sort of that
pixel density that you would get in 4k
and then you like kind of condense it
but that's only going to apply that
yeah so it's going to look super fine so
that's what you can get like there's
like i'm not going to get a scorpio hook
it up to a 1080p tv and like get no
benefit so where is that oh of course
yeah but i think if they're gonna sell
this thing for 500 bucks like i think
that that's really speaking to an
audience that is the high-end enthusiast
and they want to get the most out of
this thing the most that they can for
their 500 if they're just getting a
little bit better you know not quite and
aliasing but anti-aliasing like effect
is that enough to spend another 250
dollars ah yeah see i don't know that's
the catch that's what i'm not sure about
uh at this point michael
does it seem appealing to you do you
think you're gonna buy one day one for
well for me personally no because i i
don't really play anything on xbox man
like everything that i want to play is
either on ps4 and for multiplats i play
on pc because i have a fairly decent pc
but if i was
huh if i didn't have a console or this
generation of consoles
i still don't know if i would i still
don't know if i would make that jump
just because of exclusives
but for my taste you know
i'm as much as i am into pc hardware and
like the the most swagged out pcs that
we can like build
i mean
i don't care all that much about
graphical fidelity
because when i think about the games
that are important to me they're all
like
independent games like almost retro
style 16-bit so you don't need
all those all that graphical fidelity
for undertale you know yeah yeah it's
like one of my favorite games of all
time but you know show me some games man
like ah that's what i want and i'm i'm
hoping that you know microsoft makes a
big splash in e3 and shows us gives us a
reason to like people who are on the
fence about getting an xbox or they're
interested in scorpio but
still don't need that reason to
buy one you know
show me something at e3 yo like give me
a reason to buy that yeah it's like
as big of a halo fan as i am halo 6
might not be enough to push me over the
edge when they if they show it at e3 but
you know you don't think they're going
to
no i'm agreeing with you
no that would be that would be like yeah
the worst thing they could do is to hang
their hat on a new halo yeah to sell
this new console that would just show
how incredibly short-sighted this
company is being because that's not
anything special that's not the sort of
thing that's going to get people to
rally around a console when it hasn't
worked this generation yet especially
considering scalebound's recent
cancellation yeah that was an exclusive
crackdown 3 we don't know what the hell
is going on really well especially with
scalebound it was like it was an ip that
was like new it was something like
really experimental and exciting when
you look at games like i mean persona
and near aren't new but when you look at
what those games are doing it's so
different than the status quo yeah so if
it's just forza and halo i i could care
less yeah i do want to i sent jean-luc a
few uh screenshots earlier we they did
just release dev kit prototype images of
the scorpio uh it looks pretty good uh
see if you can throw those up now but
uh they look it looks kind of sort of
like and it looks pretty similar to an s
um
in the sense that you know it's the
pretty sleek white thing but instead of
the uh
i don't know what these is the
i don't know michael what are we looking
at here in terms of this
[Music]
look at an xbox man well
i think that it kind of looks like
because that's a original xbox one so
that's right so i imagine it would be
the same size since you got like that
all that dope hardware in there but i
mean i think those me and jimmy were
looking at this and like are those five
buttons on the left and what are they
for but yeah they're like those are leds
for like oh player one through four
connected oh and then is that the disc
tray underneath it in the black okay
yeah so i don't think those are buttons
and i think those are led lights
actually
looks good
it could be buttons to switch between
different like builds of games like i've
seen sony like ps3 and ps4 dev kits that
have like similar sort of things on them
i don't know what they do because i
haven't used them but
those were buttons on the old kits for
other systems i saw maybe help switch
things fast okay like are you saying
maybe those won't be on the final oh no
no i don't think this will be here at
all yeah cool it's uh it's an xbox it
looks like an xbox one it's a nice
looking system yeah that's pretty no
microsoft just needs a better selection
of games that is the biggest hang up
right now yeah i mean totally the reason
i still like i because i was xbox last
generation primarily and i
play multiplayer games with my dad on
xbox like that sure i mean the reason
i'm still on xbox ever
because like i think the common
complaint is like there's not enough
games um but as far as multi-platinum
stuff like if all of your friends are on
xbox you're going to
stay on xbox um but i don't think that's
enough of a reason to go to scorpio
right you can spend 200 bucks on a
refurbished xbox one exactly
yeah cool uh well yeah if uh anybody
wants to know more uh in-depth uh
info about the xbox one score or the uh
project scorpio we have uh six things
you should know about scorpio which you
wrote michael yeah i wrote that and i
voiced it yeah what's up on gamespot uh
we kind of we're doing some comparisons
to you know ps4 pro and pc more in depth
uh you can go see all that in game spot
and let us know what you think in the
comments and for those just joining us
we do have the twitch and youtube and
game spot chats up here in the studio
see what you're saying uh but yeah so
let us know what you think about project
scorpio
all right moving on to overwatch
i originally wrote down insurrection but
apparently it has since been called
uprising i think interaction was the
french one
uh
so it is the uh next
update to overwatch uh blizzard's been
pretty great about doing these community
events between uh dr junckenstein's last
for halloween they did the olympics one
before that they did uh
the chinese new year they did a holiday
one that you essentially get more skins
uh new game modes uh with a maze
snowball fight
that's essentially what it was i forget
what it was actually called but now we
have uprising and it is in terms of
story which uh you know
overwatch is pretty light on story but
it's still really good about adding
these morsels in like all over the place
to flesh out this great world and this
one is a prequel apparently it's
tracer's first mission uh humans versus
robots seven years before modern
overwatch story yeah so i'd say
overwatch is bigger on lore than it is
actually
it's better um and yeah so this is
definitely
uh just kind of building out tracer's
origin more she is kind of their poster
child so right she's uh it's it's more
of a doctor junkies junk and stains or
junketstein
junkinstein
no stein drunkenstein
berenstein bernstein bears uh but yeah
it's more of a horde mode for
cooperative horde mode uh and then of
course there will be skins uh
victory poses there'll be all kinds of
you know just new aesthetic stuff as
overwatch's one to do with loot boxes
and whatnot um quickly before i get into
this next part of the segment which i'm
excited about michael do you plan do you
still constantly play overwatch so
with multiplayer games i've noticed as
i've gotten older is that i jump in and
out of them and i have phases so when
overwatch first dropped i played that
for like a month straight okay and then
i waited like three months and then i
jumped on it again for another month
period and then i when i came here i was
like okay now i'll jump into it again
but the thing is that
whenever you add extra game modes i'm
always intrigued by that like i'm i'm
down to play new modes and keep things
fresh because as great as the base game
is
that you know having extra stuff on the
side to do kind of adds to how much i
love a game overall so having this
hormone like when halo came out with
their horde type of mode like that was
dope as well and firefight and uh
odst
yeah so
that was sweet and you know gears of war
when they had their horde mode that was
like the gender
we do have joey here uh in our studio
this is him playing right now as
reinhardt
uh yeah there we go there he is
he's got his keyboard uh so yeah joey's
gonna be playing while we talk about
overwatch's new update uh but yeah he's
uh he's playing reinhardt i would ask
him questions about overwatch but he
doesn't have a mic no uh i don't i don't
know how often he plays reinhardt but
this right here is uprising is that
horde mode i was just mentioning uh here
on the london map uh king's row um so
yeah it's about the like omnic uprising
back in the day before overwatch's
modern uh
timeline
as it were uh cali do you play much
overwatch or do you plan on getting back
into it with this yeah like michael i i
do the faces thing so when it first came
out i was playing every single night and
then i had enough people
playing that like we'd always have
someone to swap in when someone had to
leave like it was yeah
we were playing constantly um and then i
sort of dropped off from it and i've
been really wanting to go back
especially because i haven't played
like sombra or anything yet um oh
sombra's awesome i'm a i'm a mercy mane
though and i'm very loyal to her um and
that intrigues me about this mode
because this mode is uh reinhardt
torbjorn mercy and tracer um if you
don't play the all heroes version so um
i'm just always excited to have a reason
to play mercy yeah these updates are
perfect for bringing me back in uh
they're great for rewarding loyal
players and overwatch is always good
about that
uh i mean even if you're like a hero the
storm player they're they're adding
genji to it soon right there they update
it they've been updating it for years
but overwatch these are great for
pulling me back in when i mace snowball
fight or again i might be butchering
that name when that came back out i got
back into it for the skins i got uh i'm
a zarya main sorry on anna i think i
actually have been liking anna moore but
uh i just need some more hussein who's
in the chat to know that i'm better with
zarya than he is
yeah uh this this mode looks fun i
didn't actually play a lot of the
junkenstein's horde mode because there's
only four i didn't i thought maybe they
would let you select any character you
want but it was only four it was like
mccree mercy
uh i think it was reinhardt and i forget
the last characters but yeah this is
more based around tracer's story as her
i think it's her first mission with
overwatch uh before it kind of
dissipated and then obviously winston
brought him back together later on
uh according to the lore but joey you're
doing pretty well
uh
he can't respond right
he says thank you we can hear yeah yeah
uh but yeah so this is live uh on
this is live right now so you can go
play this if you want to um but yeah
this is the horde mode and of course
tons of loot boxes can get you new skins
and aesthetics and whatnot
wow uh i'm still bummed i don't have
mercy's witch
skin oh yeah that one was really good
yeah uh speaking of tamar hussein uh one
thing we wanted to highlight
this show uh tomorrow hussein for those
who don't know he's our uk editor but
he's also a very gifted interviewer
uh pete who it was harada he interviewed
right the first time we kind of were
like wow tamora might be kind of
probably yeah yeah that sounds about
right huh yeah oh no oh yeah you should
know your own from capcom okay and uh so
tamora recently did an interview with
jeff kaplan who has kind of become this
like pseudo celeb well celebrity because
uh for numerous reasons but he does all
these developer updates for blizzard uh
he's on the overwatch team he's the
director of overwatch um
and he's just this really like affable
personable guy if you don't know who he
is um but
also there's uh of course this like
youtube channel that essentially just
takes the developer updates and cuts up
the words and makes new mashups so he's
kind of become this
weird kind of halfway celebrity halfway
uh meme i guess on youtube but so it's
more sat down to interview him in the uk
um
last week a couple weeks ago yeah and so
we wanted to kind of highlight a few
different parts of this interview which
i like to compare to uh two people
uh walking hand in hand into the
oblivion uh so
just into the void together into outer
space to die together uh so we have
screenshots of the interview i wanted to
highlight and then uh i actually have a
gift for tomorrow at the end um but
yeah uh jean-luc can you pull up part of
this i'm gonna kind of narrate this
interview and kind of walk you through
how crazy it was all right so the bold
section is tomorrow asking questions and
i wanted to show you what kind of
shampoo do you use because your hair
always looks great in the developer
updates jeff kaplan oh awesome i don't
even know the name of it it's whatever
my wife puts in the shower i'm so
terrible follow-up question and yeah
follow-up question i added just to show
you how quickly it went back to being
professional
but i also
pulled up uh an image that i kind of uh
hastily made to show you uh how nice
jeff kaplan's hair looks
in these developer updates
it's just got this sheen but what if it
gets in the wind like that's what i'm
worried about how does it looks like
it looks pretty windswept and boyish to
me and i really like it and i don't
think you know it like how he slicks the
sides though not at all that's that's
some that's pro level do you like yeah
slick on the sides because that's hard
that's hard to keep up either way i wish
he actually told us what shampoo it was
because i would use it uh
no do you not shop for your own [ __ ] oh
my god uh all right moving on to the
next question pull up the next
screenshot john luke please uh this this
interview gets better as it goes
honestly uh here we go does winston like
crunchy or smooth peanut butter i think
he likes both i think if left to his own
devices it's smooth but he wouldn't turn
down crunchy either uh does jeff kaplan
like crunch your smooth peanut butter i
like smooth for sure and i love peanut
butter i'm like winston in that if i had
one food that i had to survive off of
for the rest of my life it'd be peanut
butter same
i once purchased 10 kilograms of peanut
butter just because it was on discount
nice that's awesome
again this is an actual interview we put
we conducted tamar hussein conducted and
we put on gay spot uh
yeah all right john luke next one please
did you hear the story about the girl
who called another kid a hanzo maine i
did yes do you endorse calling people a
hanzo man as a way to dunk on them uh
pretty long response but uh not as a
direct derogatory way we need to love
and respect all means including hanzo
mains it's a funny story we actually
reached out to the girl in her family we
sent them a note the parents sent back
this lovely letter to us and said we
appreciate it so much that you guys
reached out we've been talking to our
daughter about not making fun of
somebody for maintaining a certain hero
i think the whole community learned a
little lesson in there um
i actually sent john luke the jpeg of
the actual uh like teacher complaint of
the kid insulting the other one yeah i
have no idea what that means another
student took her pencil and she referred
to him as a hanzo main i have no idea of
what this means however it's clearly
meant as an insult
my embarrassing thing is that i was
actually a hanzo man for a while
that's not very yeah
all right
next
question john luke please all right this
is fantastic two to the one from the one
to the three oh what's up this is jeff
from the overwatch team
uh the rest i had there so i actually
sent john luke the youtube link if you
haven't seen this it's got i forget how
many views but this is what this is what
sparked it dinoflask is the youtube
channel so it's like about a minute and
a half i actually thought it'd be worth
it to play in its entirety uh because it
is fantastic and it highlights exactly
why he's become a meme uh just so we can
sit back and enjoy this and watch this
right now
have you seen this no it's really good
where that though
where are we at where are we at john
luke it's us again john luke
all right it's going to be a sec he's
finding it do you remember it can you
can you do something yeah well timor
just goes
two to the one from the one to the three
it's really good here we go
it's funnier with audio
there's no audio okay well we don't need
to watch it just go to you dino flask's
youtube channel um
you can watch that and you get a sense
when you're actually watching it
these get like this has like a million
and a half views i think this is what
kickstarted it so when he got announced
uh when he got introduced on the
uh what i think maybe it was like the
bafta awards or gdc or something someone
said like a
man made famous by one of the most
famous like video game memes is coming
on stage but anyway all right here's the
last part uh this is where it got pretty
weird and it's also it highlights to
moore's uh
kind of
household and i want to kind of paint
this in a way so next screenshot john
luke please
your name this is the first picture that
shows up that is awesome you should
probably do something about that what
can i do if you read so you've been
publicly shamed by john ronson he meets
people that specialize in burying
unwanted search engine results might be
useful oh really
though to be honest i think it's a
pretty good picture
and we could pull that down but yeah i
was just corroborating tomorrow's thing
and uh
that is true that is the first photo
that shows up people enjoy
screenshotting jeff kaplan when he is uh
in compromising photos on developer
updates
uh all right john luke pull up this next
one uh the one that gets really weird
this is the one i had mentioned i
thought was up next but here we go this
is uh tomorrow talking about his cat
all right so he asked uh about he said
there's a rumor about this cat hero that
they ditched and uh so jeff kaplan said
we had done a lot of concepting we had
one hero who was just a hockey player
literally a hockey player we made her
later made lucio skin for a hockey
player but he was just a hockey player
hero then there's this one here there's
a huge internal debate on the team
because we just loved it so much but it
didn't make it was this jet pack and it
had this cat that laid in it like a cat
does then every once in a while it would
paw at the controls it was a cat in a
jet pack
that was one of those moments that
helped define overwatch we just went
yeah that's probably too far but yes we
had a cat hero and tamora being of sound
mind said that sounds incredible and you
should bring it back
and then i'm going to go he has yes i
have two cats named kiki and i want to
really try to explain this as best as i
can he doesn't have two separate cats
each named kiki
you will just be in tomorrow's apartment
and look over and see those two cats and
you'll call it a collective collectively
the pair of cats is kiki because they
don't leave each other's side they are
collectively named
so
i was reading that and it was funny but
i was really disappointed that they
didn't include that cat hero so uh as a
gift to tamora and jeff kaplan i reached
out to dan our on our design team he's a
designer here and we made kiki
we made the cat hero
uh kiki with a jet pack that is the
collective pair of cats named kiki with
a jet pack he just got a sick play of
the game i like to think of it as an uh
an offensive character uh and yeah that
was my gift to timur and jeff kaplan uh
do with it what you will blizzard if you
want to that is dan our again uh anyway
i'm so happy yeah that was uh that was
that was my uh
redemption for them not actually making
the cat hero so anyway yeah if you want
to read that whole interview it is on
gamespot.com it is even weirder if you
read the whole thing uh so go do that
and uh
go play overwatch
all right
thank you john luke
tomorrow saying is in our youtube chat
and uh guys oh my god all right sweet
so uh let us know if you're gonna be
going back to uh overwatch's uprising uh
update uh when what you think of that
cat hero and sign a petition or
something to make it real all right
here we go uh we in terms of another
interview that we did on gamespot uh
scott butterworth did a a really good
interview with uh jake solomon the lead
on xcom2 and xcom over at firaxis
and he in the aftermath of
mass effect andromeda wanted to talk to
him about
why some aaa games are kind of like
doomed to foul before they're released
or why they are kind of uh you know
going up against obstacles inherently um
jake solomon i believe is that gdc was
giving a speech about why failure is
important in game development and how to
learn from it so scott wanted to reach
out about that and use you know mass
effect as a time peg and we all kind of
wanted to talk about that aaa
development is kind of uh
you know an amorphous thing it's hard to
pin down and uh obviously with
publishers with developers there's a lot
of money involved and sometimes that is
inherently at war with the creative
pursuits of some developers and we also
kind of wanted to touch on
how fan input affects development and
again if you want to go read this whole
interview scott butterworth did a great
job talking to jake solomon and it's a
great line of questioning and it's
really insightful if you want to know
more about a pretty prolific
aaa developer
but yeah i don't know i kind of wanted
to uh this isn't really too concrete of
a segment but i wanted to talk to you
guys about what you think you know in
the aftermath of mass effect andromeda
um i don't know um
it's it's interesting to like look at
what failure even means for a triple a
game because sometimes even if it
doesn't have critical reception it still
sells it can sell really well like
andromeda sold yeah a lot of copies and
but you know critical reception i think
overall was kind of disappointing um i
think you know people are saying it's
it's a fair game it's good a lot of
people really like it a lot of people
dislike it it's uh it's pretty
polarizing but i don't know uh michael i
don't know what's your take on kind of
just in general
what does it even mean to you know walk
that tightrope between this publisher's
aim of making money and uh the developer
trying to be you know have creative
pursuits yeah so there's one aspect i
was kind of throwing around in my mind
was the deadlines like the the pending
pressure of a deadline
has to like get something done whether
it's good or not whether you as a
creative like artist or whatever like it
doesn't really
matter what you think of it you have to
make that deadline and so i think that
when developers reach a point where it's
like okay these things like we can ship
this product with these things missing
or with these um like aspects rough and
we'll patch it out later as long as we
hit that deadline because it's not self
uh imposed and when it's not
self-imposed you can't like it's harder
i imagine it's hard to be like okay we
need like six more months before we push
out a like a finished product yeah
because you're like beholden to the
publisher yeah but the bigger problem
though is that you're beholden to money
because milestones are what these
deadlines are actually referred to and
there are many of them throughout
development and if you miss them you
will not get it you'll not get paid as
much as a studio working for a publisher
in some cases so you can actually miss
your deadline but you just won't make
money back oh okay so it's it's
partially the pressure the publisher is
putting on the developer but also the
developers saying
we need this money to continue doing
what we're doing and pay everyone and do
everything that we expected to do on
time it's a weird mix of the two yeah
cause andromeda had development studio
troubles kind of throughout its five
years the people that had previously
worked on mass effect games or other
bioware projects left the studio i know
mack walters was there throughout the
whole thing and he was there for release
but a lot of people looked at it and
said this might have been a case of ea
just wanting to get this game out right
before the end of their fiscal year so
they would have made more money in that
fiscal year yeah i mean sometimes no
it's not just like a like a one case
scenario like i'm describing like
especially the publishing date that's
super important right but there are
things that you have to hit like during
the course of development that can
if if they're not given the time and
attention they need you know a year
ahead of time that's going to reflect in
the end as well
and also another thing is that you know
post release defining failure is that
you know like same thing with no man's
sky no man's sky sold incredibly well
but
like what's the lasting impact of
releasing that game is that you know
by and large you leave a bad taste in
everyone's mouth and then so when like
when hello games wants to make another
game or when bioware comes out with
their next project you know you have
this aftermath even though you sold your
game your previous game incredibly well
made a lot of money um you know what's
the what's the effect on your future
projects like have you failed at that
point or
are you more doomed to fail at that
point because of this reputation from
your previous game so i mean that's kind
of more nebulous i suppose but that's
one thing to think about too as a
consumer when i
when a game comes out i'm like oh what
have they done in the past what was
their previous project like should i be
invested in this yeah i mean that's a
big determinant of uh how excited i am
for a game if i don't know the like if
it's a new ip but i know this the
developer or i know somebody who worked
on like not personally i mean but just i
know their work i'm like oh i really
liked the way they wrote this character
i can't wait to see
what they do with this game um
and the converse is true too where if
you get burnt by a developer you
just
probably going to go into their next
project a little more skeptical of it kg
nafune comes to mind yeah uh one thing
jake solomon had said uh scott asked him
if there's kind of a fear
especially after mass effect andromeda
because it was bioware montreal's first
title as a collective studio of course
there were people there from earlier
titles but um if there's a fear that
your first failure could also be your
last and that might be what determines
your you know like your career um i had
asked i believe it was richard garriott
who used to work at uh looking glass way
back in the day and then he did stuff at
origin and now he's at portalarium down
in austin and he's also like an
astronaut and [ __ ] now because of stuff
he did back in the 90s he essentially
like established immersive sims with
warren specter and paul nerath but he
was saying that you know there's that
mantra that the developers is only as
good as their last game right like kgm
funeral comes to mind too um i don't
know i think the one you know we
remember record remember money number
nine i i think about that before i think
about like the good mega man games now
um and then scott had been asking jake
if that fear is there and jacob and
saying yeah it's kind of throughout
development you're trying to learn from
failure but also trying to push away the
fear that it might sink you as a
developer and uh but then i want to look
at more positive uh games as well uh
kali you had mentioned doom p you
mentioned breath of the wild for games
that
it seemed like you know the development
studio there's a lot of trust placed in
them and they kind of just prioritize
maybe different things then
i don't know this might be reductive
than ea might have with mass effect for
instance um in terms of breath of the
wild how do you think that kind of isn't
the antithesis to the negative side of
triple a development um well i think
that kind of boils down you know to a
quote that maybe miyamoto has sort of
you know instilled in a lot of people in
nintendo and he definitely has a lot of
sway there um which it's along the lines
of you know a delayed game is eventually
good a rush game is bad forever right so
like they understand that if they
publish something shitty
that will sort of be the legacy that is
that you guys were just talking about
just now like that will be the
persistent legacy until they can fix
that somehow right
but now like with a great success like
this like they will be able to earn
people's favor much more easily down the
road so
yeah delay this game a couple years to
make sure that you can keep people on
your good side
yeah kelly and then you mentioned doom
right because doom got delayed for a
while and then doom came out that was
like one of the better games last year
one of the best shooters in the world
yeah i mean i do the original was one of
the first games i ever played and uh the
thing about the
new one
um was that it felt
like
they respected the legacy of doom but
um
didn't
feel stuck on it like it didn't feel
like stuck in the past either like it
was
a newer take on something that i loved
when i was younger and i just i thought
they did a fantastic job with it and i
thought it
like a lot of people were like oh the
music is really garish but um i think it
fits the spirit of doom like that just
like over-the-top heavy metal like oh
yeah we're gonna kill demons like i just
adored that game so much and i loved
finding the um
like i think the collectibles were
really good and the uh being able to
find the um
16 bit or whatever levels you can go
kind of find those little mini levels um
i just i loved so many things about that
game and i think it was better for the
delay yeah there's another interesting
part of this jake solomon interview uh
in which he was scott asked him if
you know
when you see games in early access all
the time and uh you know kickstarted and
these people are kind of you know like
supposedly have a say in development
these fans uh jake or sorry scott was
asking jake you know at a certain point
is it more about the fans what they want
in a game in a triple-a game or is it
more about what the developers want to
push out and then scott asked the
question you know if it becomes all
about the fans is there the danger of
making it a poorly designed game because
fans might not have the same knowledge
as developers and might not have the
same probably definitely don't have the
same creative intent as developers um
and then you know
p you had mentioned like a lot of times
over the years when you interviewed
developers back in the day
or even like questioning would literally
be to them who knows best about your
game you or the fans
and jake solomon is the first person
that ever said the fans
and he continued to say something along
the lines of like
i have no grounds to get defensive about
people criticizing my design decisions
because it's a game i'm making for them
and that to me is just kind of insane
because that draws a line in the sand
between making something you're really
passionate about or making something
that you think is going to sell or just
like please an audience which
this is a business that is very
important right but at the same time
there has to be an interesting balance
and he is just so far onto one side of
that that discussion
it's very surprising to hear that yeah
normally i would say maybe that's just a
pr response maybe because he sounded
very candid yeah no but he is throughout
the years he's always been kind of
saying that he said when they first
started because to reboot xcom on 360
and then uh you know the enemy within
it was a huge it was a slog like uh
there's i think there's a feature on
polygon a while ago about like just the
stress it put on him for like over 10
years between pre-production and finally
releasing it and he was saying the
entire time there was also the fear that
fans of the original xcoms back in the
day the isometric ones would be just
hate him right um and maybe that played
a part in his subsequent you know uh
being beholden to fans but i mean
there's certainly responsible for him
being able to do what he continues to do
right so why would he want to
screw that up like that that's easy to
sympathize with
um but at the same time like yeah i just
i feel like there has to be a better
balance there and i don't think that his
work shows a lack of that balance
uh but his answer yeah again it just
made me
i don't know he didn't he didn't seem to
like see both sides yeah there's a bit
of an anomaly um but you know like i
think stuff's worth talking about and
it's a great interview you should go
read it between scott butterworth and
jake solomon it's on gamespot it's
called uh xcom director on why some aaa
games fail um it's pretty insightful in
terms of uh you know aaa development
developing these uh huge budget games uh
for you know like you know these huge
sales uh but it's worth going to uh to
read especially in the wake of mass
effect andromeda which a lot of people
criticize in terms of its uh its release
state um it is
improved now uh in some aspects there
was the patch that released and it
helped some of the animations those eye
things technical issues stutters and
whatnot so
if you have been holding off on mass
effect andromeda maybe go check out some
of our coverage on that and see if it's
worth going back to in the meantime let
us know what you think about this
discussion uh we do have the twitch chat
and the youtube chat up right here but
also if you're watching this uh later on
on youtube or gamespot uh let us know
you think about
aaa development and uh maybe what your
takeaways are from that jake solomon
interview if you get the chance to read
it
all right michael
thank you so much for coming on i'm
gonna boot you off for our uh resident
star wars expert peace out man yeah have
a go have a good uh day wait what are
you working on the rest of the day this
weekend
tech stuff yeah i'm doing some tech
stuff some uh most of it's under nda so
let's keep what is it
trippy man all right thanks michael all
right peace out y'all we're bringing on
uh dr
robert hanlery uh he messaged me on my
walk home last night and he was saying
oh battlefront 2 teaser trailer just
leaked uh and cali will be at star wars
celebration orlando as of friday morning
uh so you know like star wars stuff
gearing up we're all like hoping and
praying for an episode 8 trailer as well
at the end of
that's disgusting did you actually just
touch your tongue with that no
don't rewind that
all right uh but we want to bring rob on
because he was uh texting me pretty
furiously
about how some of our predictions that
we were kind of nervous about after uh i
think it was last week we did what we
won battlefront 2 we're like
[ __ ] we didn't even talk about like uh
the new order or whatnot and everything
we're like that would make sense because
that's the last movie that came out and
we were talking about the clone wars
we're like what were we thinking but
then rob text me he's like dude it's all
three arrows i'm like oh now we look
kind of smart uh but i wanted to bring
you on we were gonna have jean-luc and
back kind of scrub through the teaser
trailer uh from what you say you know
like there's a decent amount of things
you looked at you went crazy like
scientists looking at there's uh a
little more that you might have missed
yeah by the way 30 second quick trailer
so here it is we'll just kind of watch
it once yeah um you know again just to
preface all this like this is still
going to be a lot of speculation i mean
you know what is confirmed right based
on this is that you are
playing as i would believe a female uh
imperial officer of some sort but after
return of the jedi so post
death star too
the fall of the empire which i think is
it's kind of surprising but it all it
ultimately makes so much sense as far as
okay they want to tell a story that
hasn't been told this is all ideally
and
that has not really been told that whole
gap and there was the book after math
and all that stuff but this is still
untouched and also they probably have a
lot more freedom uh as lucasfilm i'm
sure everyone knows it's like constantly
gripping right like they are very
uptight with anything it's you know it's
their baby
um
so it's a great timepiece i mean that's
super interesting yeah it does it seems
kind of like what it's doing what rogue
one did in the sense that rogue one kind
of it didn't really bridge the gap
between revenge of the sith in a new
hope but it still filled in some info
that we did that we had only heard
alluded to in a new hope what is this
what are you doing
yoda and kylo ren in the same trailer
okay no so that's that's where if
there's one thing that we mentioned last
week or predictions
that seems to be the case is that we are
going to get the hero system so when you
say timepiece that's what i'm like oh
like i understand like that part you're
describing but then it just all kind of
gets flushed down the toilet when they
show like everyone's here yes i am yeah
the harlem globetrotters i am on board
with you uh so darth maul got yoda you
got ray and you got kylo ren to me to me
what this infers again the hero system
strictly for multiplayer i would be very
surprised if they are going all over the
place in the single player campaign i
think yeah i think the single player
campaign this time around which you know
like if you don't know battlefront 2
does have a dedicated single-player
campaign with a story and everything uh
i would be surprised yeah i mean like
they would keep i'm assuming they'll
keep the multiplayer that kind of star
wars toy box aspect you know like star
wars fantasy like battlefront 2 yeah and
then you have uh this focused
single-player story which will fill in
the gaps between return of the jedi and
of course away force awakens yes i don't
know how far because i think they're
also playing it safe where uh it's still
like familiar original trilogy right
like i mean
they're still star destroyers they're
still gonna be tie fighters granted
there were tie fighters you know
obviously force awakens but
um i'm curious to see how far they go
because i mean what's that gap it's like
over 20 years i believe
at least yeah so
i i wouldn't expect to see
any major i mean you might see snoke
maybe that's i mean
that's when he picks up everything right
so maybe that's and you know i could
almost see like
uh
the character you play as defecting in
the end almost like a fin kind of role
it seems like they're kind of taking
pics so if we have the trailer we can
kind of start combing through because i
have yeah got a couple cool notes on
luke throw that up and rob can kind of
uh narrate it and yeah so i mean
yeah you're inferring because there's a
voice right she sees i believe the line
i should remember the line if you pause
it right here uh go back does that hurt
the protagonist i would imagine that's a
close-up i mean like someone is talking
right now and she i think she's along
the lines of like the emperor's dead we
need to get revenge right so she's still
with the empire remember
yeah yeah so this is endor um now these
are not your typical stormtroopers right
these are kind of like
it's like almost like they're pulling
from rogue one right with those uh the
death squad troopers um oh these look
like more like pilots to me that's what
i'm gathering to so this is where it's
all speculation however uh
again i was looking at all the reddit
stuff um if you watch rebels the show
that droid they're hovering around uh
right there obviously on the left is uh
an id9 seeker droid bam wow john luke
it looks like a imperial probe droid
from far away yeah but they're a little
cooler mike uh supposedly these in the
show i've not seen the show um
unfortunately but
they uh they crawl they fly they mimic
other droids there's they have
electric probes they're they're kind of
like a cool sidekick okay so i can see
that
playing a nice role as you are
which now is speculation even further
is that you play so this is a character
that that's uh from the rebels she is a
jedi hunter like a sith inquistor
imperial inquisitor um
is that the role you're playing because
you're not you're definitely not you
know if you were to
compare it to finn you're not a janitor
right yeah you're
higher up you're flying around in that
slick looking ship that it reminds me of
darth maul's uh
infiltrator uh
you're you're higher up
is what i'm i'm under the impression of
i mean she she specifically she sounds
kind of like lament full about she's
like i remember the last orders i had or
i can't remember the exact line but
she's talking about that and she's
called the un like the untold soldier
story right so that's very likely it's
weird because you know like force
awakens uh a big thing with finn is that
they're kind of implying he's not just
this normal person because i'm wondering
why like the imperial brainwashing
whatever they do wouldn't work on her
specifically like why would she have a
change of heart
oh that's a good point um
well maybe the whole thing was finn is
everybody's theory is oh he's force
sensitive he really is and then that's
why he was like turning around that's
why phasma did the whole like go back to
conditioning or whatever force awakens
in in this era of the three eras uh how
stormtroopers are um
picked or is you can volunteer it's
possible that she volunteered just as
the rebel the fight with rebellion got
worse they they needed volunteers sure i
mean and i would i would say that you
know
as this new first order is being
established maybe that's why she defects
again who knows if she does or not but
yeah look at that like helmet in the
back yeah right sick these this seems
like a pretty unique squad i think are
they implying that that's the helmet she
would be wearing if she had one on
because that's a red helmet in the back
i don't know reading too far no but
that's a cool helmet it looks like a
black storm trooper with like a red on
the side red touch and you know what
that's like that reminds me of first
order right that's what yeah the first
order so blatantly vamped on just like
or there's red nazi stuff she has red on
her
right shoulder yeah yeah um so if yeah
we can just keep moving along um there's
not a whole lot yeah so this is this
reminds me a lot sorry this is darth
maul's cruiser the infiltrator i believe
is called
sith infiltrator and it looked it just
reminds me a lot of the ship you see
this is small i would say like a smaller
form so if you keep playing or now start
the trailer really i think it kicks off
with that
um
perfect
uh rewind a little more yeah like the
first shot i think had a better take of
it i know jean-luc is frantically
scrubbing um and again more about you
know this trailer was 30 seconds it felt
quick
and we have been told uh that we're
expecting something really big right a
really big reveal so this weekend right
i feel like this is just a tv ad you
know i mean it felt very spoon fed with
all these this text like so here's this
classic uh dog fight so that's
starkiller base so you can you can
definitely count on uh maybe replaying
that battle from force awakens
um in multiplayer
uh or like i mean ideally in my what the
hell yeah
[Music]
exclusive gamepl
awakens was really neat with their um
you know it reminds you a lot of again
like world war ii like nazi red flags
like yeah blatantly evil and that's what
was so neat about force awakens so
you're seeing a lot of that here which
is really neat right like the tree and
the flag in the background i think that
is a cool visual style and palette that
works well we we've seen it in
battlefield one you know i mean with
like a lot of orange and like against
just really bland dark desaturated
ground
it's cool uh if you keep going um
this is a
pretty
uh obvious nod to the first trailer
right or when the resistance is coming
in exactly and that is the uh i wrote
that down what's the plan because i
don't remember it to kona i didn't write
down when they go see uh moz
oh yeah what is that to the temple god
it's the new cantina planet yeah yeah
uh so you can imagine some stuff there
and of course what everyone's
remembering is all right
which to me says we're going back to
hoth and i don't give up
f about hoffman i think that is just the
most tired
level in in all star wars games i just
don't care even walkers i don't know i
like
and that's where i think it's it's not a
bummer but i think it's like again smart
i mean everyone knows of imperial
walkers and stuff like it's just
it's interesting it's an it's a cooler
story new locations
yeah it's kind of the same stuff and i'm
hoping for
for rebel vehicles to be honest
if it is a tv spot then it would make
sense that they would include more
like the most recognizable imagery i
think um and it i mean
yeah yeah no yeah it's a good point i
mean let's hope that's
i don't know anyone's funny thing too is
like you know think about battlefield
uh one
like the horse like their head horses
it's like
someone was just like dude let's do don
dolls
[Laughter]
i don't know it's just like funny thing
and then obviously here's
maul and yoda because you know remember
that
this just instantly turns me off
dude it bothers me so much it's just an
easy way to devalue these characters but
i mean the original not that this makes
it okay but the original battlefront one
and two had
like these kind of battles in the
multiplayer and they did it well i think
because it was more about you know just
this star wars fans fantasy in the
multiplayer sure which i'm fine with
that here if they do use like that more
uh gritty boots on the ground soldier
story that seems like i mean based on
this teaser they're going to do and we
already kind of have the fantasy thing
in the last game and the one from years
ago right so that's what i'm saying i'm
hoping i'm getting more grounded thing
in the single player campaign so if
they're just gonna do this in
multiplayer then that's i guess that's
fine if they can do it well um but i'm
hoping like
i don't know you can keep scrubbing
through i guess rob but yeah i just i
don't know i again we talked about the
hero system
i mean there's you know there's a part
of me that wants to see how they do like
kylo ren right you see him in the end
yeah if you remember from the movies
like he did stop a bullet
from
uh
like full speed heading towards uh well
how'd that even happen i forget
who shot that it was uh poe dameron yeah
i mean he just stopped a bullet like
that'd be a cool move but again i don't
care to play as any of these heroes yep
yeah uh
so that is just
like a straight-up shot from
force awakens it looks like not in like
actual shot but very reminiscent it is
interesting to me that they are yeah
including the clone war era prequel era
which we actually said we hoped for
because that was the one redeeming
quality for me for the prequels was the
the actual you know the battles the
clone wars themselves they were covering
i think cali you and rob you both said
the same thing you were hoping yeah i
really wanted to do like actual battles
like on a larger scale i'm i'm less
drawn towards the individual like hero
stuff than i am towards um the grander
scale of it yeah
is this this is toward the end of the
trailer right yeah yeah this is it okay
and then here uh
obviously like i mean there's that like
ro you know it's funny how they're just
like it feels like they're nitpicking
different aspects you know i just keep
thinking of gender or so like the that
one shot
which i never end up using in the movie
but you know just that uh imperial pilot
look it's cool and then also in the
background someone pointed out like
separatist ships i can't really
i guess on the left there that's a
separatist ship oh uh confederacy yeah
yeah i'm i'm wondering if they're gonna
focus too much on rogue one if they
already did all that dlc with the first
game
oh
well if you see the bottom there you're
definitely gonna get some last jedi yeah
stuff yeah yeah
oh my gosh wait what you can
oh my god i i'm speculating okay and all
the old luke skywalker the cane yeah all
right well anything else to add are you
okay actually i want to ask you guys are
you uh more excited for the game now
after seeing this yeah i'm i'm much more
excited about this game uh namely the
single player i think that's cool
i'm i'm really hoping
they uh do something neat with that yeah
like tell a really interesting story and
again like
that's hard to do
in
in a universe like with the original
trilogy or any of these because it's
been told like how do you tie in a
character with
uh
uh you know
fan favorites like i hope they don't do
that as much obviously but there's it's
like it just feels like a clean plate
and that's really nice kelly you'll be
seeing this soon a couple days three
days or so yeah i'm i'm really excited
i'm
uh
i'm gonna be that person and say i'm
always more excited uh for like more
female heroes in star wars um just
because that was i was really into star
wars as a kid and that was the one thing
that was always missing for me so um i
the kid in me it gets just really
excited about having another female hero
to
um whose story we get to tell and i am
also one of those people who liked rogue
one i really enjoyed rogue one so
i'm excited about the prospect of doing
um
sort of like you were saying a more like
soldier
war focused sort of thing with her so
i'm very intrigued by her
you don't seem too excited
i mean
i'm with you guys right i like the idea
that's going to have single player
there's there's like how do we know it's
going to be any good how do we yeah i
know yeah like i i can't get excited for
anything yet because this sure this is
literally just like people you love
ships that look awesome you love star
wars right
okay i don't think you do love star wars
pete
i like star wars when it's not just
exploited for the just yeah just to sell
things dude i am 100 i hope they pull
more from battlefield 1 than they do
from battlefront
with this
like being dice i hope yeah they take
cues from battlefield 1's gameplay
i don't want i don't mean story-wise
like i don't want
like stormtroopers running into the
trenches on
verdun or something that's not what it
meant you and i are just a couple of war
shooter fans yeah that's just yeah i
mean tell that story and that's where
i'm i'm a little concerned as well
in that uh of what like action not
gameplay obviously that we've seen
it still looks exactly like battlefront
yeah and like
again
one of my frustrations with battlefront
was just
the lack of like diversity it's just
like imperial walkers
rubble's getting stomped on but i i am
really overseeing that and
that is littered with it and it looked a
lot like battlefront it looks good but
it looked a lot like that last game so i
i just yeah again i really want to see
some new stuff but that's what's neat
about this idea is that
at least for the single player like yeah
it seems a little more open-ended yeah
all right well people watching if you're
in the chat right now or if you're
watching this on youtube or game spot
after the fact let us know what you
think about battlefront 2 let us know if
you're excited for it let us know if we
missed anything in the trailer that you
noticed and uh this weekend we have a
lot of uh star wars coverage between
battlefront 2
and you know we're hoping they're going
to show the last jedi at the end of star
wars celebration maybe after that panel
uh rob do you have coverage planned in
the case of that happening damn right on
friday yeah you wanna uh peter myself
and uh josh shaw will be um an hour and
a half before what we are expecting to
be the
uh release and reveal of the first
trailer for the last jedi which is uh 9
30 um
pacific time pacific time yeah because
it's in orlando so we are going to play
star wars games up until what we believe
that revealed to be it's like 8am you're
gonna start playing star wars games 9
30. we're hoping they're revealing
that's right
um well we we're planning to play
multiple but i think we're just going to
play rebel assault too because yeah so
if you're not playing shadows the empire
i'm not watching
go sucks oh my god we were talking about
it oh my god the other day dude
i honestly of the 364 games of squadron
pod racing and
shadow
i like i'm more reluctant to play rashad
get a poster of shadow it's got rad
cover art that game sucks dash rendar
yeah cool name
i like your jetpack dash rendar
if there's one thing we're definitely
going to do for shadow and the only
thing i want to do and then we can
switch is sewer level
is uh the code remember how you did oh
yeah
yeah we had it not watching you had to
hold every single button on the
controller and then move the stick
halfway to the right halfway to the left
back and forth and i remember doing it
as a kid i was like well i guess i'll
just use my mouth
hey rob i need you to help me what are
you doing exactly a couple times like
what are you doing
um podracer i'm done talking for the
rest of the day all right good it's
great okay and then the one sorry sorry
off but then the one is uh and peter was
showing me because i've never played it
yeah rebel salt two two yeah has like
has some of the most amazing fmv
yeah really bad fmv really bad game play
yeah but does it have uh
can you trip atats before you could wait
can you and razzle salt 2 no
you can shadows the empire and that was
the first time i did that and so many
other stuff yeah subscribers just talked
about how overkill that was i like lego
star wars
there you go hey lego lego star wars
owns anyway uh yeah awesome better than
shadows
yeah we'll also have more on uh
battlefront 2 this weekend because of
celebration so look out for that uh yes
so stream eight o'clock pacific time
these two jamoks will be playing uh all
these shitty star wars games leading up
to the hopeful 9 30 uh pacific
announcement
of the first last jedi trailer uh callie
will be having some battlefront two
stuff like she said coming out of
orlando this weekend she'll be able to
have more uh hands-on impressions or no
no hands on okay she'll be able to see
more eyes on
eyes on ears and eyes yes oh and yeah
i'll be able to hear it as well
yeah and if you're in the twitch chat
right now khaleesi plays that is shiva
who managed their twitter account she
just posted the link to our lobby
giveaway if you missed it earlier in the
show go follow gamespot if you don't on
twitter and then retweet that giveaway
tweet later on the week we'll pick a
random winner to get uh that corsair
strafe mechanical uh pc gaming keyboard
uh yeah so look forward to that uh
triforce tomorrow you and rob will be
playing zelda what's the do you know
what you're doing for this episode yeah
last week was so good if you haven't
seen it yet i think it's pretty special
please go watch last week's because i
was like cackling at my desk it was us
that are
worst
maybe best but mostly worse yeah for
those of you who don't know it's period
peter and i play uh legend of zelda a
little differently or try to so
triforce
i just got that oh my god
uh last week one of us was uh
blindfolded the other one was directing
we did uh across the whole map tried to
do it and it was
exhausting on the mind we
also take a shot every time rob says
describe it to me
describe it to me
i mean don't because you would probably
die that with all poisoning um but this
yeah this week uh peter you want to
explain it yeah we're going to do
eventide event tight island but no
weapons only ruined powers
uh so
yeah just just ruined powers i mean it's
like a challenging thing anyway so
without any uh equipment that you would
find along the way it might be a little
bit harder i just hope we can do it now
i think about it because
the last thing we'd want is be like all
right it's two hours but at least we can
see this time how are you gonna get the
octo balloon you need
what i guess we'll figure that out
[Music]
once we get to the island and
do you really need one on the island
oh yeah
they have this really good hat too it's
good i made that in like 10 minutes like
right before the stream it's still in
the stream room i had a dream that if
you had like an hour to make that hat
how glorious it would have looked
oh my god this was this was the one of
the worst parts right here it was that
was found a henix sleeping
and i'm like oh this is a breeze we'll
walk around it and then
he just wakes up
i
oh my god it was
i was freaking out i was like there was
a part of me was like oh my god we're
we're done like this is like every
minute in the stream
it is so hard to tell someone how to
play a game when they're not looking
turns out at getting him to parry the
laser shots though that's hard
you were able to time that really well
and peter was really good at messing
with me it's an experience just getting
you to put the wrong
i was like
i was like i could put my climbing gear
on and he's like okay and there's a spit
i'm hovering over a lasalfa monster mask
and i was like is this it
he's like yeah that's it it's like this
is convenient he's like oh
i didn't find out until later because
eventually you started hearing the
noises of it and i was just like
you looked great super funny you looked
great all right everyone so yeah tune in
tomorrow for triforce that is the
episode they'll be doing that episode
tomorrow pete just described on eventide
island uh and like i said we might have
a diablo three stream sometimes a week
for the uh necromancer i have to double
check with eric tay we might not uh but
yeah thank you so much for joining and
uh as always we will see you next week
it'll work eventually there it goes
[Music]
you